péchenard bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat aux côtés de valérie pécresse
en ile de france on est ensemble pendant
une vingtaine de minutes jules halki
julien lécuyer pour vous on ne vous
présente plus bonjour julien merci
d'être avec nous on va parler bien sûr
des régionales mais avant ça peut-être
un mot sur l'actualité c'est annonçait
hier de jean castex la fin du port du
masque en extérieur à partir
d'aujourd'hui bonne mesure bonne
nouvelle surtout voilà parce que c'est
vrai que on a été quand même très très
contraint par cette épidémie puis il
fallait prendre toutes les dispositions
donc tout ce qui peut alléger le
dispositif dont le respect bien sûr des
règles sanitaires est plutôt une bonne
chose et donc je me réjouis de ne plus
porter le masque comme beaucoup de gens
je pense et je me réjouis aussi de la
levée du couvre-feu
est-ce que malgré toutes les critiques
qui ont été faites par l'opposition ça
ne signale pas finalement le la réussite
du pari d'emmanuel macron du congo de
déconfinement je pense que des
confinement a été menée non pas comme la
dernière fois
brutalement mais là il a été mené
effectivement progressivement et
honnêtement je pense que c'était plutôt
une bonne chose parce que l'on sait pas
du tout ce qui va se passer à la rentrée
on voit bien quand même de ce virus à
une certaine saisonnalité ce qui fait
que l'été ça va mieux
bon je crois que la critique qu'on
pourrait faire en tout cas le risque
c'est qu'on n'est pas assez de gens
vaccinés
voilà ce qu'est concrètement on voit
bien qu'on ne sortira définitivement de
cette épidémie que quand la quasi
totalité des français seront vaccinés
aujourd'hui on a 15 millions de français
qui sont complètement protégé c'est à
dire les deux avec les deux doses ça
fait 1 français sur 5 pour manifestement
c'est pas assez est ce que ce n'est pas
la responsabilité des français aussi
dans le sens où beaucoup rechignent
encore à aller se faire vacciner
c'est vrai une partie de la sensibilité
de chacun mais je crois qu'il faut
pousser les français à y aller il faut
peut-être qu'il a fallu faire des
campagnes plus massive de de publicité
sur la nécessité de se vacciner
peut-être il faut rendre dans certains
endroits la vaccination obligatoire
je pense par exemple aux aux ehpad a
finalement aujourd'hui on a réussi avec
ciné à peu près tous les gens dans les
ehpad on vaccine également les gens qui
viennent les voir mais par contre on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un trou et qui a une
partie non négligeable des soignants des
ehpad qui ne sont pas vaccinés quelques
dans les ehpad il songerait à l'endroit
la vaccination obligatoire forcément où
les soignants pas forcément que dans les
ehpad juge donne cet exemple là mais il
est certain que les gens qui sont au
contact de personnes fragiles et
devraient être vaccinés prioritairement
ça a été fait mais peut-être parfois les
les obligés parce que sinon et si on n'a
pas ces personnes vaccinées ba a priori
noté une reprise d'à priori en yens
il ya un risque de reprise de l'épidémie
et on sert français on sait pas grand
chose sur cette épidémie on sait de plus
en plus de choses au fur et à mesure
bien sûr
enfin on voit bien que la solution passe
par une une vaccination très importante
des français et c'est ça vraiment qu'il
faut pousser très directe pesztat vous
êtes le monsieur sécurité de valérie
pécresse la sécurité c'est pas une
compétence en de la région on l'a déjà
beaucoup dit mais on en parle quand même
beaucoup de cette sécurité à l'occasion
de cette campagne
si on en parle autant finalement c'est
que vous avez échoué peut-être à
diminuer l'insécurité en ile de france
non je crois au contraire que l'on a
réussi quand on a commencé il ya six ans
un voté le bouclier de sécurité
rappelons sur les 13 régions
métropolitaines y a que trois
vice-présidents la sécurité c'est à dire
qu'il ya les autres régions estimé que
la sécurité s'était pas du tout un enjeu
pour eux c'est pas inintéressant de le
souligner les trois régions ça pas vous
surprendre c'est d'abord ile de france
mais sur votre la région était la région
paca et la région rhône-alpes sur votre
bilan dès le départ nous avons décidé
valérie pécresse a décidé de faire de la
sécurité un marqueur mais la région n'a
pas de compétence sécurité 7 nous sommes
là nous région pour aider donc le
bouclier de sécurité qu'est ce que c'est
rapidement c'est un dispositif pour
aider les mères sa première chose
les mères qui veulent avoir une police
municipale les mères qui veulent avoir
la vidéoprotection mais nous finançons
ça et pour aider l'état sait c'est que
je souhaite est très important
maintenant le régalien
c'est l'état c'est le gouvernement c'est
la police et justice et la gendarmerie
voilà alors vous êtes responsable quand
même de la sécurité dans les transports
et dans les lycées
oui absolument alors on partie
d'ailleurs dans les lycées dans les
transports puisque c'est une compétence
qui est partagée naturellement avec
l'état sion pour les transports par
exemple
eh bien nous avons recruté 1000
personnels de plus quand nous sommes
arrivés il y avait 2000
or police nationale et gendarmerie y
avait 2000 personnes qui travaillaient à
la sécurité dans les transports c'est en
général de la sncf gpsr de la ratp et
nous avons financé le recrutement d'une
1000 personnels supplémentaires te fait
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez 3000 personnel
or police et gendarmerie qui sont là en
plus alors ce qui est dommage
et on se bat pour ça en ce moment c'est
que dans le même temps l'état a retiré
500 policiers et gendarmes de la
sous-direction de la police richard les
transports précisément à l'effort que
nous avons chez nous l'effort très
important lors bush 2000 personnes a été
effectivement un peu amoindrie mais vous
permettrait de s'assurer mais m en effet
ce chiffre en valeurs à suivre en valeur
celui que qu'on vous reproche souvent et
a fortiori à la présidente de l' île de
france valérie pécresse qui était
ministre du budget à l'époque de nicolas
sarkozy et qui a vu la baisse de 12
mille fonctionnaires de police durant
son mandat
alors lorsque c'est pas contradictoire
non pas lui d'abord c'est pas 12 mais
fonctionne de police ses 12000 personnel
du mystère à l'intérieur d'une façon
générale ensuite c'est quand même
quelque chose qui remontait à 10 ans à
simon blais finalement pas du tout pas
du tout je vous dire pourquoi on s'y
fasse encore ce déficit en aura 100 la
grand chose reprenons l'exemple des
transports en commun est ce que il y
avait mille trois cents policiers au
sein visé par au service à la
sous-direction la police régionale des
transports en 2012 quand j'ai quitté mes
fonctions de directeur de la police
nationale
ils sont mille aujourd'hui alors
peut-être qu'il ya plus de policiers je
sais pas où ils sont en tout cas ils
sont pas en ile-de-france et en tout cas
ils sont pas laissés localisation d'île
de france
ensuite et aussi pour répondre
rapidement votre question le les
effectifs c'est quelque chose qui est
très important dans la police mais ce
qui compte d'abord et avant tout se
réfléchit en termes de missions
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire faire la
police et en fonction des missions
il faut mettre des moyens et ses moyens
ce sont des hommes et des femmes bien
sûr mais ce sont aussi des moyens
techniques ce sont aussi des voitures ce
sont aussi des gilet pare-balles ne soit
pas périmé donc il faut prendre dans sa
globalité et enfin je terminerai pas en
vous disant que je pense que les
français et le gouvernement serait très
heureux d'avoir une session sécuritaire
qui était celle quand nicolas sarkozy
était présent dans le public quand
valérie pécresse est ministre quand
j'étais directeur général de la police
nationale la délinquance besset et
pas d'actes de terrorisme en france à
l'exception très importante de celle de
2001 il y avait eu un attentat
terroriste sauter à tort métropolitain
on n'avait pas eu d'affrontement en
termes de maintien de l'ordre comme on a
eu les clés gilet jaune et je peux vous
dire que les solutions sécuritaires
étaient bien meilleurs que j'ai servi
aujourd'hui pour vous pouvez vous
répondre à la question que pose et steve
juste juste avant pensez-vous avoir
endiguer l'insécurité en ile-de-france
est ce que c'est une un échec ou pour
vous une réussite soudain faudrait bien
prétentieux pour prétendre qu'on a en
biais ou que ce soit endiguer la
délinquance en ile-de-france alors qu'au
contraire les chiffres lui mis ses
intérieurs sont plutôt mauvais y compris
d'ailleurs sur les faits les plus graves
ce sont les amis site volontaires les
homicides volontaires c'est pas
inintéressant que chacun ne
l'entendaient le sache ont diminué de
moitié entre 1992 et 2012
deux fois moins ce qui était quand même
une très bonne nouvelle un pays où on
tue deux fois moins c'est pas un pays
qui est plus violent depuis 2014
lentement progressivement le nombre les
homicides augmenté a énormément d'argent
mais un pas énormément mais ce qui est
intéressant dans le temps dans les
chiffres de la délinquance et pas de
comparer à un mois sur un mois ou de
balancer des chiffres comme ça c'est les
tendances en criminologie
là on a une temps sur cinq ou six ans ça
peut s'expliquer par tout un tas de
raisons mais c'est en tout cas c'est le
symbole probablement un signal du nom
c'est un fait ça c'est un marqueur de
l'augmentation de la violence dans notre
pays d'une façon générale et d'ailleurs
et de rassemblement national
c'est quand on fait de la sécurité c'est
le régional nous dit on veut pas ce que
vous je vous demande et parce que ce
n'est pas de notre compétence nous
région
je gardais lakic ou qui siègent au
conseil régional n'a jamais voté
favorablement une seule de mes mesures
j'aurais été contre bouquet de sécurité
n'ont pas voté pour les brigades
régionales de sécurité dans les lycées
parce qu'ils estiment que c'est de la
compétence du régalien ce qui s'entend
sauf qu'aujourd'hui le régalien est dans
une telle difficulté que nous estimons à
la région comme les maires peuvent
estimer qu' il faut que tout le monde se
serre les coudes
voilà dans le cadre d'un continuum de
sécurité ça commence à la police
municipale ça finit au ministre de
l'intérieur ça passe aussi par la
sécurité privée
on s'occupe aussi la formation de
sécurité privée l'année dernière
167/1000 carte de policier privées de
sécurité privée ont été délivrés
déjà plus de sécurité privée que de
sécurité publique en france on parle
beaucoup de répression cette criminalité
ou le volet prévention dans votre projet
alors je ne sais pas où je vais parler
de répression c'est pourtant un sujet
qui m'intéresse beaucoup et je serais
ravi d'en discuter avec vous pour
l'instant j'ai parlé ici j'ai pas parlé
de le répression
mais puisque vous me lancer sur ce sujet
le sujet qui me paraît le plus important
dans la lutte contre la délinquance
c'est mettre fin à l'impunité c'est ça
qui est le plus important
et pourquoi est ce que paient ce
sentiment d'impunité parce que les
peines sont peu ou mal appliqués moi
toute ma vie de policier gt gt
commissaire de police pendant 30 ans
j'ai entendu dire les policiers justice
les magistrats au large mais ce n'est
pas vrai je le dis très sérieusement ce
n'est pas vrai les policiers arrêtent
les magistrats condamnent
c'est après que les et l'exécution de la
peine n'est pas fait correctement et
c'est cette manne exécution des peines
ou mauvaise exécution des peines qui
crée ce sentiment d'impunité
la faute à qui il faut lutter c'est une
question qui est purement politique
purement politique alors il ya un
problème de moyens financiers
si vous n'avez pas assez de places de
prison il faut en construire messiah
problèmes de budget et puis par ailleurs
il ya un problème de choix politiques
concrètement quand vous avez trois mises
la justice successifs
madame taubira madame belloubet monsieur
dupont moretti sur les mêmes visions
pour qui le mot sanction de nos prisons
est un gros mot eh bien vous créer une
espèce de situation d'impunité
je le prends l'exemple de 2
du délinquant qui a giflé le président
de la république il a été arrêté il est
passé en comparution immédiate c'est
normal un acte de violence ça se passe
dure toujours comme ça les comparutions
immédiates ce quelque chose qui
fonctionne plutôt bien dans notre pays
il est condamné à quatre mois de prison
ferme avec mandat de dépôt
ça signifie qu'il va aller en prison ça
signifie qu'il va faire probablement
deux mois de prison
je trouve que c'est une peine qui est
juste et qui équilibre et il est normal
vous ne pouvez pas j'y fais pas standard
public impunément s'il n'y avait pas eu
un mandat de dépôt si le juge n'avait
pas délivré un mandat de dépôt et et
finalement tout dans la politique du
gouvernement fait en sorte qu'on ne
délivre plus les mandats de dépôt eh
bien il serait sorti et la peine
n'aurait jamais été mise à exécution
moi ce que je demande c'est pas des
peines quand je compliqué ce qu'est ce
qui n'apporte qu'une réforme de la
procédure pénale comme les syndicats de
police je rejoins dit besoin de réforme
de la procédure pénale
sur ce sujet là puisque ce qu'il faut
c'est la certitude de la peine dont un
mandat de dépôt à partir du moment où
quelqu'un gifla policiers frapper un
pompier agresse un maire il devrait être
sanctionné donc avec une peine légère
mais une peine avec mandat de dépôt
et ça je pense que ça mettait ainsi fin
à un certain nombre de sentiment
d'impunité et ça permettrait à
l'autorité de l'état de se réaffirmer
regardons d'autres d'autres points du de
votre programme en termes de sécurité
alors vous
vous prenez la reconnaissance faciale
dans les transports alors vous dites
qu'il faut avancer doucement vous sentez
bien quand même que le le sujet est très
sensible
la cnil la commission nationale
informatique et libertés elle même est
très réservé sur sur l' usage de cette
reconnaissance faciale qui oblige à une
collecte massive de données biométriques
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'on va trop
loin dans la surveillance généralisée
des jeux
ce que je pense et vous avez raison de
le souligner je pense d'abord qu'il faut
être extrêmement prudent quand on voit
ce qui se passe par exemple en chine et
la façon dont sont organisés la
reconnaissance faciale en chine avec le
rapprochement et les réseaux sociaux
il n'y a pas de reconnaissance passe
c'est faciale qui qui est inquiétante
pour nos libertés
je suis parfaitement conscient de ça je
dis juste une chose c'est que quand une
technique existe bel vous est persuadée
qu'elle est employée
et donc ça sert à rien de lutter contre
une technique par contre ce qu'il faut
c'est l'encadré je me souviens des
discussions il ya de ça quelques années
autour de l'adn et autour du fichier
national des empreintes génétiques ou
c'est un bouleversement c'était c'était
nouveau
il y avait des gens qui étaient
violemment hostile bord les pour les
libertés bien aujourd'hui ça fait à peu
près vingt ans vingt ans qu'on a ce
fichier d'empreintes génétiques 20 ans
la politique fixée et scientifique a
beaucoup progressé
vingt ans ça a été tout à fait encadrer
à l'arrivée qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se
passe on a un fichier qui a permis
d'arrêter des centaines d'assassins des
milliers de violeurs ça permet également
dû disculper un certain nombre de
personnes voilà et donc je pense que il
faut il on peut pas tourner le dos à une
technique mais ce qu'il faut c'est
l'encadré sérieusement la reconnaissance
faciale
ça existe comme technique jeu j'étais il
ya quelques temps l'or valeur c'était
avant le c'était avant que vit donc s'il
ya plus d'un an mais je suis passé par
un sas paraphe dans un
dans un aéroport eh bien il utilise la
reconnaissance faciale c'est à dire que
vous êtes face et vous mettez votre
passeport
un match donc vous comparez avec le
fichier des empreintes génétiques mais
elles sont prélevées sur des personnes
qui ont déjà été condamnés le quand on
parle de reconnaissance faciale pour
qu'elle soit efficace ce système il faut
qu'ils collectent les données
biométriques de personnes qui n'ont rien
à voir avec un quelconque idée non
l'idée se serait imaginé en effet que le
moindre pékin que ce soit vous ne soyez
pas ce violon tout je touchais pas
besoin de contrôler et de collecter les
données après le tout c'est de ne pas
les garder mais c'est ce qu'on propose
à vrai dire c'est tout ça et dans la
perspective des jeux olympiques de 2024
les les transports et les réseaux ferrés
les transports franciliens seront
évidemment une cible terroriste pendant
les jo de 2024 donc qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
alors ce qu'on propose c'est
d'expérimenter aux côtés de l'état
évidemment n'est pas question qu'on
puisse faire les choses tout seul ça
sera d'ailleurs techniquement et
politiquement impossible aux côtés
l'état d'expérimenter la reconnaissance
faciale sur les terroristes dire qu' on
puisse mettre dans notre base de données
un certain nombre de personnes
condamnées suspects et officier des
radicaliser pour pouvoir les identifier
si ces gens sont dans la déception sur
ce sujet avec gérald darmanin on en est
aux balbutiements
on parle de manas que vous avez un avis
sur la missive confidentielles qu'il a
envoyée aux préfets pour taper plus fort
que sur les hauteurs de rodéo urbain
c'est une bonne chose on peut pas
laisser faire les rodéos urbains passé
c'est insupportable pour les gens qui
sont autour pour les riverains qui
habitent c'est dangereux pour ceux
qu'ils le font et là aussi ça montre une
impuissance de l'état que vous avez un
certain nombre de personnes qui roulent
à force ouverte n'importe comment dans
les rues d'un certain nombre de villes
c'est dangereux c'est insupportable en
termes de bruit
et puis c'est un atteinte une atteinte
une fois de plus à l'autorité de l'état
donc tout ce qui peut aller vers
la répression répression et la sanction
ou la prévention d'ailleurs puisque dans
cette missive notamment il ya un aspect
préventif qui est de confisquer
préventivement un certain nombre de quad
deux roues etc va plutôt dans le bon
sens
vous approuvez en quelques mois la
politique de gérald darmanin
actuellement à je n'applique je
n'approuve pas la politique du
gouvernement en termes de sécurité
maintenant si vous voulez me faire dire
ce que je pense de gérald hardy a offert
jeu je pense que c'est un bon ministre
autre mesure que plus étonnantes
valérie pécresse a annoncé que réélu à
l'offrir et une aide de 100 euros pour
se doter d'une alarme chez soi alors
elle a estimé le coût à peu près à 10
millions d'euros
est ce vraiment à la région de proposer
cela à vrai dire ça tout ça correspond à
des demandes nous avons eu un certain
nombre de demandes à la région les gens
se tournent peut-être d'abord vers
l'étape demande de la vidéo par exemple
un moment donné il ya eu des agressions
et des et des violences et des
mutilations sur des chevaux un peu
partout en france et notamment en ile de
france et bien les les propriétaires de
ceara ou de ces clubs hippiques
souhaitait se doter de vidéoprotection
et ils nous ont demandé de les aider
donc tout ça correspond à des demandes
et ben on entend les demandes on est là
pour cent quand vous allez lui lyon
d'euros vous pensez que ça il faut les
dépenses et pour ça je ne vois
personnellement pas d'inconvénient si on
peut aider les gens à se sentir plus en
sécurité si on peut les gens et si on
peut aider l'état à augmenter la
sécurité
je pense que la région dans son rôle il
ya intérêt régional direct au sens de le
nôtre fenech péchenard si valérie
pécresse elle gagne ces élections le 27
juin ne sera peut-être pas très
longtemps alors là sera peut-être pas
très longtemps présente deux régions il
va falloir lancer cette campagne
présidentielle alors oui
leur partie alors je vais parler de mon
parquet les républicains mais nous avons
souhaité en jambes et enfin 2 2 une
vague après l'autre si vous voulez a
c'est à dire que on s'est focalisé sur
les départementales et régionales
mais dès que les régionales seront pas c
est bien la grande échéance ça sera les
législatives
et bien sûr la pression sociale et
pécresse serai une présidente de région
intérimaire en quelque sorte valérie
pécresse serait serait conditionnel
puisque je suis pas son porte parole
une excellente candidate pour la droite
je pense qu'il faut absolument
absolument éviter le duel qui ce que
tout le monde prépare entre emmanuel
macron et
et marine le pen je pense qu'il ya une
place pour quelqu'un de la droite
républicaine
je ne sais pas encore qui ce sera mais
valérie pécresse plus que xavier
bertrand
j'ai pas de à ce stade je pense que
c'est pas le sait pas le monde en
parlait en tout cas je suis sûr qu'il a
merdé soyez par le candidat
la méthode employée par le votre parti
est républicain pour un obscur il est
vrai encore assez difficile à comprendre
pour choisir le candidat attendre lé
real et réels et les résultats des
régionales voir comment ça commence à
phosphore
regardez les sons organisé un sondage
est ce que tout ça vous paraît pas quand
même très compliqué c'est pas très
compliqué c'est qu'on est face à un défi
qui est unique pour nous on est
probablement le parti de france le plus
important on est majoritaire au sénat on
a le premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale on a une majorité
on gouverne d'une majorité de villes et
et j'espère demain le département et de
région
mais il nous manque nous n'avons pas ce
qui est finalement le plus important
pour l'élection présidentielle ne vont
pas quelqu'un qui incarne à l'évidence
ça n'a pas de leader naturel à
l'évidence alors on a un certain nombre
de personnalités de très haut niveau
les gens qui ont été ministres qui ont
de l'expérience qu'ils ont comme valérie
pécresse ou comme xavier bertrand
admirablement géré d'airé des régions et
il faudra trouver un système de
départage parce que évidemment il n'est
pas question que le parti fusse cnir
deux candidats qu'est ce qu'elles
représentent ces élections régionales si
vous perdre une région par exemple par
exemple la région paca qu'est ce qu'est
l'enseignement vous allez en tirez pas
si on perd la région paca on en tirera
l'enseignement suivant c'est qu'il faut
rester fidèle à ses valeurs et à son
parti et c'est comme avant sans droit et
sans ambiguïté qu on gagne et c'est pas
en cherchant de mauvaises alliance c'est
à dire que vous crédite critique et
clairement tout ne toute idée de
d'accords techniques avec un autre parti
quel qu'il soit la région ile de france
il n'y aura aucun accord avec personne
valérie pécresse a fait une liste de la
droite du centre extrêmement large
il ya dlr la justice civile il ya lui
dit
il ya des gens du modem qui ont siégé
avec nous qui ont quitté le parti et des
écologistes dans cette liste c'est une
liste qui est très ouverte
c'est cette liste qui sera présente au
premier tour et qui sera présent au 2e
tour vous critiquez donc la stratégie
par exemple qu'on entend revenir du côté
des pays de la loire
je crois qu'il faut pas chaque région
est différente moi je suis aujourd'hui
complètement a parlé de deux ans je suis
à 100% dans la région je suis tête de
liste à paris donc je ne pense vraiment
qu à paris qu'à la région ile de france
après si on arrive en tête quelque part
et s'il ya une liste qui veut se
désister et apporter son soutien je vois
pas d'inconvénient à ce que on parle
quand on ouvre les bras
peut-être d'intégration de saclay de
fusion mais en tout cas d'intégration de
certains de certains membres
nous non ça c'est et nous verrons pour
l'instant ça me paraît un peu prématuré
on réglera ses problèmes la semaine
prochaine au sein du parti
on verra aussi quelle est la position
prenant les autres ans j'ai entendu
monsieur dupont moretti dire qu'ils
venaient dans les eaux france pour
combattre leur assemblée nationale si
ils arrivent en troisième ou quatrième
position mais qu'il est en mesure de se
maintenir au deuxième tour s'il se
maintient il ya un risque et fasse
gagner le rassemblement national
on verra ce soir là s'il met en accord
ses principes et sa position politique
l'allemagne elle macro et dans les hauts
de france je crois un julien aujourd'hui
alors vous croyez bien si il sera dans
la somme et dans et dans l'aisne avec
comme grand thème la lecture qui qu'il
va annoncer comme une grande cause
nationale pour la la fin du du
quinquennat est ce que ça vous
s'agace un petit peu cette façon
d'égrainer les annonces de faire ce tour
de france de prendre le pouls des
français alors que se déroule la
campagne des régionales au mois vous
pourrez tout à fait honnête et pas grand
chose qui m'agace ce que j'ai vu
beaucoup de choses dans ma vie donc mais
je peux faire un constat par contre on
peut faire un constat que disons que ce
tour de france qui ai commencé à 15
jours d'élections majeures que sont les
régionales départementales monte jusque
une chose c'est l'implication politique
forte du président de la république dans
ces élections
dernière petite question il sera à
château-thierry le président de la
république un ville natale de jean de la
fontaine
petite question votre fables affables
favorite à vous c'est quoi le corbeau et
le renard
pourquoi parce que tout flatteur vit au
dépend de celui qui l'écouté
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'il ne faut
jamais oublier spécialement quand on
fait de la politique on nous a pas
flatté a priori non merci
péchenard merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions à voir les autres listes des
candidats en ile-de-france on lit onze
listes au total sont sur la liste de
départ merci encore frédéric péchenard
d'avoir répondu à nos questions julien
pour rester avec nous si vous le voulez
bien pour le club des régionales parce
qu'on va partir dans votre région les
hauts de france du ray ce matin c'est
parti on y va
[Musique]